on the embankment wall facing parliament
there is a heart for every single
coronavirus victim in britain
and for those who have a loved one
represented here this scandal
has been particularly hard to fathom
fran hall is part of the kovid 19 buried
families for justice group
she lost her husband steve in the
pandemic last year
the country as a whole we've done what
we've been asked to do
so to find out that it doesn't apply
this rule
of keeping your distance and not
interacting with other households
two people in charge is just it's so
disappointing
and it's so worrying as well because all
moral authority has gone
regaining that moral authority will
clearly not be easy though
that much evident at an anti-lockdown
protest in central london just hours
before matt hancock's resignation
but sagitt javid faces several other
challenges too
15 months into the pandemic nhs staff
are at breaking point
not just from their physical toil but at
what they see as a lack of recognition
unions are still demanding the
government increase its recommended 1
pay rise to prevent staff leaving
then there's the backlog of patients
more than 5 million on the formal
waiting list for treatment
and an estimated 7 million more who've
stayed away from hospital during the
pandemic
the pressures are unprecedented so his
first task
really is to restore some calm he needs
to
give the reassurance that he's fully
informed
uh about the position we're in he knows
the science he knows where we are
and that he needs to ensure that he asks
for trust and that he's going to offer
that back
to the public even for an experienced
pair of ministerial hands
it is not an easy task the government's
locked down mantra of togetherness
in danger of falling apart iva bennett
sky news